on verra qui on attend pour vous dans un
instant bien entendu mathieu qui marie
n'en prenais le livreur vous avez foi
fait quoi et berit et vous délivrons pas
moins sa demande mais il prépare il n'y
a pas de nom il sait pas où il est mais
l'application sa part d'air canada
ça va permettre de manger peut-être
démène nous pour tout le monde et c'est
parfois pour ce côté là hélas ici alors
j'ai une question à vous poser est ce
que quand on vous confier un secret on
peut faire confiance non non c'est cher
g et vous le savez d'echery j'ai une
maladie
ouais j'ai une maladie c'est comme je
vais pas vous mentir voilà tout ce que
me confier la direction de canal+ à la
base c des secours
ici j'ai une maladie je balance tout
c'est parce que j'aime je ne sais pas ce
que j'ai et à chaque fois en plus la
direccte le ghana plus vous les mecs de
canal il dit je répète pas de sous tu
connais pas justement et là je raccroche
avec eux tu sais pas quoi j'ai une
maladie
voilà je voulais une syncope ce que
serait le concept de garder un secret
pour vous c'est compliqué nous mais non
mais voilà alors par exemple je me suis
souvenu de comment les téléspectateurs
avaient appris l'existence de pato
schwenheim me souvenais plus en fait
vous balancer que soient vos
chroniqueurs ou les amis vous balancer
tout lasse manière vous avez balancé le
secret d'un chroniqueur yann encore
traumatisé alors je pense qu'il est
temps d'ouvrir les marches yves
alors je reçois un texto d'un dénommé
tiéné maurice albe elle alors c'est pas
moche c'est toi jean louis qui la
donnaient titi et donc on se souvient
aussi que vous avez balancé l'antenne
votre désormais ex ami ramzy qui était
amoureux secret de qualité de vie mais
là c'était plus grand secret non plus
rappelez-vous lui il a une personne
assez son coup de coeur tous les copains
de ghazi le savent la fin c'est il est
fou amoureux et donc le pauvre hamzé
même pris un râteau en direct avec
souvenez-vous la compassion mythique de
questions clavier deux grands frères
spirituel et tu en fais partie ah merde
t'es pas sérieux à fred
[Musique]
oh
et bien la semaine dernier alors qu'ils
n'avaient absolument rien fait vous avez
décidé de balancer un secret très intime
ce que vous avez confié jean michel
maire vous allez voir qu'il va mettre
deux jours en s'en remettre sa tête
extraordinaires sont très bien les flics
français feront très bien les flics et
puis bien sûr vachement plus après dans
la prévention quand ils vous arrête
c'est toujours beaucoup plus convivial
et c'est à vous si vous êtes policier
mais vous arrêtez michèle merli défoncé
mais sans permis
[Musique]
ça s'est parlé
hormis ça va c'est mon ami on dit tout
et puis chez que je suis la pire des cas
je vais me chercher je le rappelle bien
sûr ce détour c'est surtout sur les
autres mais vous mais je vous adore mais
c'est vrai je l'entends d'une nouvelle
édition balances ton poste l'émission on
voit ces logos transformés en arlette
chabot 2.0 et vous receviez la chanteuse
mesnel exactes aux médias qui avait fait
polémique à quelques temps dans the
voice et voulait demander pour quelles
raisons elle avait enfin que c'est
peut-être venant de branche ton post
harry et sa réponse forcément ça m'a
obligé à proposer un nouveau look baba
[Musique]
la leur mais neil c'est vrai qu'on se
demandait tous ceux qu'elle devenait
mesnel déjà pourquoi avoir accepté
l'invitation de balances ton post
honnêtement si j'avais accepté c'est pas
pour te voir sert il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je regarde c'est vrai qu'ici je la
regarde souvent pour des missions parce
que voilà on vous regardera bah oui
c'est christine d'accord c'est carrément
s'écrie-t-il ou karim wade de sa dépense
alors je dis c'est la deuxième un petit
nouveau
yann moix alors moi j'étais impatient
d'assister à la rencontre entre cyril et
yann moix la rencontre entre deux férus
de littérature deux hommes qui se voit
réunis par l'amour dont les auteurs
français du siècle des lumières
alors vous connaissez la recherche de
toi + moi bien sûr mais maintenant il ya
toi + moi que ça j'adore mais oui mais
bien sûr ça fait dix ans que vous êtes
habitué à des interventions de
chroniqueurs comme par exemple celle ci
je vous fais un cube sauf que vous avez
décidé d'embaucher yann moix prix
goncourt alors forcément à chaque
intervention
on a l'impression d'être en cours de
philo en terminale elle vous a qu un
militant à quand vous vous préparer ben
justement à la fin du monde et vous la
peur que ça arrive est toujours
inférieure la déception que ça n'arrive
pas alors ce que dejan motte les
toujours hyper intéressant que vous
allez voir que même les chroniqueurs et
sont parfois un peu perdus on peut
considérer que une oeuvre soit au dessus
de la personne qu'ils créent et un
[ __ ] peu ferdinand oeuvre parce que
c'est un des billets que la nature a
inventé pour six à arracher à la
médiocrité
il ya toujours des nouvelles peurs qui
font que les survivalistes auront
toujours un avenir et sont des gens qui
à mon avis partagent la même morbidité
que ceux qui ont toujours tourné vers le
passé
ils sont enfermés dans le futur
mais ce que je préfère c'est quand cyril
hanouna fait semblant d'acquiescer
pendant les monologues de yann moix
quand ici de grands auteurs l'art est
une idée manière que l'homme a pour
s'extirper de cette misérable nas de son
tas de secrets misérable comme dit
malraux qui est lui même tout seul avec
la prof classe côté retrouve avec
quelques pas les caténaires et des
voitures lancées bah oui c'est comme
c'est ça non alors pas du tout mais
c'est oui oui non mais y aura la suite
de la prune fois mais j'imagine salle
albert sont deux
j'adore c'est évident alors on le sait
la belle mourinho c'est une grande
journaliste média n'a bien sûr en temps
de matinée sur rtl 15 ans de télévision
4789 heures d'anecdotes isabelle sait
tout faire donner un faux médiums aussi
fait rire la france avec ses bons mots
encore son humour au vitriol à vos
chiens pour l'instant on vous a pas
encore proposé les césars pas encore non
du mans garde mais vous y travaillez 5
et bien voici le grand retour de grand
mère c'est faire un bon café mais pas
des bonnes vannes mer c'est faire un bon
café mais pas des bonnes vannes et
j'aurai une photo de neymar où il a les
cheveux roses les deux boucles
d'oreilles comme ça qui pendent patrick
et je lui dis tu vois là il ya tous ces
gens de mer et est opératrice de vers de
terre travaillée sur la gynécologie du
ver de terre que j'ai déjà vu des vers
de terre dans des slips sont les couples
à que ça repousse
voilà merci maman est-ce que l'on peut
porter un vêtement que l'on vient
d'acheter alors il faut mieux le laver à
temps parce qu'il ya énormément de
produits chimiques non mais c'est comme
quand tu rencontres une meuf envie de la
pécho tout de suite mal à mettre en jeu
pareil tu atteins pas envie d'attendre
mais d'abord
tenez j'ai découvert mon héros c'est le
mec qui s'enchaînent aux armes pour
éviter qu'on les coups bas proposé à
chaud on peut pas le faire trop comment
tu vois ce qui l'attend sont pas dit le
vieil adage dis moi ce que tu as dans
ton panier je te dirai qui tu es
si vous voyez que le gabon voilà il a
que des préservatifs
attention à la main au panier ça prend
tout son sens à mais c'est de là mais
[Applaudissements]
samedi soir c'est la dernière grande
barque 1 avec cauet comme invité c'était
ma dernière la dernière la dernière
émission ses mains ont été encore la
chronique en revanche pas grave c'est
pas grave il s'est passé beaucoup faire
ces missions j'étais obligé d'y revenir
dessus
je veux résultats en 50 secondes 25
secondes inside et on commence avec la
révélation de l'année vous avez fait une
révélation de malades on s'enfonce et
quelle est la place de cyril hanouna sur
canal+ j'étais halluciné 50 secondes ça
ici sinon t'as pas pris six nations j'en
appelle aux dirigeants de séville francs
capitaux et gérald brice viret et
vincent pujol il faut refaire un plot et
tod
si je tape plus haut je m'appelle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous avez une très bonne
analyse du planning des émissions de co
et à la radio dès 19h batteurs deux mois
après les faits dénoncés 18h20 et
maintenant il est de 16 heures ça marche
tellement bien que même maintenant il
est jusqu'à 20 heures et après 20 heures
c'est un best-of de cauet lancé par une
meuf ça me fait penser un peu à notre
consoeur s'est vite quand laurent baffie
apple tire ardisson sont plus un
animateur de tout le monde en parle vous
adore cyril franchement c'est fou je
suis très content madjo soeur me l'a dit
à l'ehpad
moi je travaille je suis avec cyril
hanouna te l'aiment bien
et puis laurent baffie avait envie
d'appeler quelqu'un auquel personne ne
s'attendait à l'est on a maintenant
karaboue sort car c'est la paix qui joue
ouais mais schultz et le logement
je commence à m'inquiéter appelle moi ça
l'aurait ferreira michou sa vraie patrie
alors selon référé un michou c'est sûr
montrent qu'il y en a un qui savaient
pas rire du tout du tout regardé ça
m'inquiétait appelle moi
[Musique]
demain soir j'adore
[Applaudissements]